yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah feedback was good on the three
videos that I posted today only mention
was that it felt like him the the sound
was a little bit low which I'm trying to
address here I've turned it up a notch a
six is a somewhat odd move okay I'm just
claiming that age three years kind of
okay so now we get the this is a bad
line with a six extra black this line is
pretty awful with the pawn on a seven
and I don't really believe it can make
much of a difference yeah it's a bit
surprising that highly rated clear like
this sky is playing into this line with
this really which is really quite bad
this is just one way to punish it
there's also Queenie of three instead of
Bishop c4 which is quite strong what
seem it's difficult for black to develop
yeah this is this is the relatively best
move so just going to develop my pieces
and see how he's going to free its
position yeah this is an interesting
moment I'm not quite sure if I should
rather take or let him take that's an
interesting question really I think I'm
going to take just because I takes with
the king Wow
okay not sure I needed this really with
with the King on d7 so I wanted to
develop like this anyway Bishop to f4
and then castling long cancer in Queen
side kinky 7s an odd move
really I wonder if g5 is actually
something that black wants to do maybe
okay this is very likely preparing
Knight to d5 I just want you make this a
little bit more difficult for him to do
and if he goes like a 98 or something
I'm just going to not move the bishop
and try to let him capture it certain if
that was really that great anyway I'm
going to castlelong next and then see
how he's going about it I think she
wants to play Knight if I really really
badly
I think 94 though is a good reply it's
night see five all those moves are
really annoying and black definitely
does not want to take on e5 I don't
think so long castling is probably good
anyway so let's not argue about that too
much
just wonder what I'm doing next here
okay so I'm giving up on predicting any
move b5 it's like complete madness
so how do you want to do that just looks
extremely extremely weak weakening its
easiest to just play ninety four and I
probably should do that shouldn't think
about this too much the main danger here
is to in this game is to do something
stupid with the clock management the
position is very good the bishop is not
good on b3 we should do want to f3 is my
idea if he takes e5 this action
interesting question because both
captures make sense pawn takes makes a
little bit less sense now as there is no
good d6 anymore if he decides to take on
e5 hmm yeah here you can actually decide
to take and play Queen to e5 and then
put it on to f6 mm-hmm anyway I wanted
to Bishop should be 125 I definitely
don't want to trade Queens that would be
but Queen f4 is actually quite strong 25
there's Queen f4 that's really awkward I
think for him as f7 is under pressure
and maybe this isn't so clear because f6
can be played I actually thought f6
after 25 anyway I have to go back
yeah so let's go on the desired square
five really allowing b5 next okay so I
have a clear plan yeah
just c4 I'm not sure that this is
helping actually oh I mean I didn't pay
they didn't pay attention anymore to be
honest because what plaque did was so
awful you really think okay he's never
going to play any decent move
I didn't didn't pay attention to that
okay the position is actually still
quite playable because I mean it was
just so dreadful what he played before
but it's still somewhat interesting
you don't know if this good cup g6 is a
one more threat so here yeah yeah time
is not great I know
yeah I don't I don't really I don't
really do this way Liam this is so quite
bad it's a full bouquet it's such a
shame to lose this game because I mean
yeah we will look at we look at this a
little bit in the analysis but it was
like winning with Ares basically
anything that's what I did okay I mean
this is just like g4 you know like here
you can this is sugar cake check just
totally winning
I just g3 whatever just don't blunder a
piece and c4 is going to kill black I
mean you made every single positional
mistake that you can make the opening
was basically this is just not playable
I don't you just have a busted position
and that that continued like this king
be seven is weird yeah I don't know I'm
not doing anything special I'm just
developing pieces and he kills himself
step by step I just don't I shouldn't
blame the pieces and this is just the
thing yeah it's really not much the same
it's just like black got completely
killed I can't play see who I
immediately as everything is like plus 2
or plus 3 and I think even with the
blunder the position is probably still
unclear yeah
I'm blundering a full piece and the
position is still not clear because I
mean yeah ok g4 I went see for more then
Jong yeah you're just trying to make
something happen here with a piece down
c5f was also probably I don't know in
fact I was kind of having some chances
oh I'm blundering this in which you
didn't didn't take
Wow okay this is the first game today
and I don't feel quite awake but that
was really bad
and then I stumbled into Bishop g5 yeah
I mean his his bishops are now very
strong of course and okay it feels like
my brain was not quite quite own in this
game which again is quite a bit of a
shame because I mean if you like play
moves like b5 and so on you really
should win the game with white but
blundering stuff is overruling all kinds
of strategic madness if you blunder
pieces it really doesn't help if the
other guy plays um yeah like
strategically and suicidal doesn't
really it doesn't really help okay I
hope I'm awake after this game and going
to play better next time thanks again
for watching